Друзья давайте Сегодня поговорим о
блогерах как отличать реальных экспертов
от мнимых экспертов как
а узнать или отличать тех блогеров
которые дают реальные знания которые
могут принести пользу в вашей жизни и
которые абсолютно бесполезны И вообще
как развиваться используя социальные
сети и большое количество экспертов Вот
именно сегодня я хотел бы с вами об этом
поговорить первое С чего хотелось бы
сразу начать - это прежде всего нужно
вам научиться чётко разделять экспертов
с реальными знаниями от мнимых экспертов
К сожалению в современном мире и в
социальных сетях очень много мнимых
экспертов как нам это отделить так вот
для того чтобы отделить теоретиков от
практиков Давайте сначала поймём В чём
недостаток теоретиков Ведь они же вроде
транслируют тоже какие-то нормальные
знания так вот проблема вот в чём Когда
вам говорят какие-то теоретические
знания как правило они используют общие
формулировки и общие знания
теоретические знания проблема
теоретических знаний в том что их очень
сложно применить на практике можно даже
сказать что порою даже Их невозможно
применить на практике Да с точки зрения
формальной логики или человеческой
логики они звучат Логично но применить
их в жизни очень сложно порой и
невозможно так вот как определить а
теоретиков от практиков прежде всего
Давайте поймём вообще что такое знание
понимание и опыт для того чтобы нам
уметь различать блоггеров А давайте
поймём что что это вот эти три понятия
разделим знание - это в моём понимании
информация структурированная
определённым образом вокруг нас весь мир
состоит из информации все звуки являются
информацией выраженной там в битах вся
картинка вокруг нас тоже является
информацией выраженная в пикселях И
вообще всё что вы видите слышите
воспринимаете всеми органами чувств -
это информация так вот чтобы
ориентироваться в этом мире люди начали
эту информацию структурировать
определённым образом все например
информация про растения стала ботаникой
вся информация про животных называется
зоологи вся информация про камни про
камни называется геология и таким
образом люди взяли всю информацию
окружающую нас поделили на кластеры и
это стало называться знаниями но сами по
себе знания не меняют нашу жизнь для
того чтобы начать менять свою жизнь нам
нужно не просто знания получать от
экспертов у нас должно быть понимание
или у эксперта у эксперта должно быть
понимание А что такое понимание
понимание - это усвоенная часть знаний
то есть заметьте не всё знание а
усвоенная часть знаний которая состоит в
том чтобы человек понимает как это
устроено И причинно-следственную связь
так вот если человек берёт только знания
и не видит причинно-следственную связь и
как это устроено то он не сможет вам
объяснить э как это применить в вашей
жизни и третий очень важный момент у
эксперта должен быть опыт А что такое
опыт вот вроде кажется у человека есть
уже знания и понимание теперь он Эксперт
Но на самом деле он ещё и не Эксперт
настоящий Эксперт - это тот у которого
уже есть опыт А что такое опыт опыт -
это основанное на прошлом понимание того
что работает а что нет Именно поэтому
так высоко ценится опыт потому что
только опытный человек понимает что
работает а что нет и для того чтобы
понять какой Эксперт реально является
практиком А какой Эксперт является
теоретиком обязательно посмотрите на его
биографию или послужной список чего он
достиг каких результатов он достиг какие
результаты он показал может быть он
крутой только в одном деле которым он
всю жизнь занимался А вещает про другое
Поэтому очень важно посмотреть а его
портфолио либо те проекты которые он
сделал либо те результаты которые он
достиг дальше после того как вы примерно
для себя определили или разделили
блогеров на теоретиков И практиков я
кстати очень Настоятельно Рекомендую вам
слушать именно экспертов практиков
потому что только они говорят как
применять их знания в своей
непосредственной жизни после этого вам
нужно
разобраться или понять для себя теперь
Как извлечь пользу из этого блогера
поэтому очень часто возникает такой
диссонанс вроде бы тче опытных эксперта
говорят разные вещи Хотя в их
экспертности вы не сомневайтесь и очень
часто люди задают вопрос та кто же
всё-таки прав и здесь я хотел бы
привести аналогию вот Представьте что вы
пришли в какой-то Дворец спорта и там
секция карате секция айкидо секция бокса
секция борьбы секция Кунфу и так далее
ваша
задача на этапе выбра в какую секцию
идти включить мышление и для себя
привить В каком направлении вы будете
развиваться и после того как вы выбрали
например каратэ идите туда и слушайте
только этого эксперта всё от этого
эксперта и развивайтесь в этом
направлении потому что парадоксально
конечно но в этом мире они все правы и
каратист прав и Кунфу прав и Айки дошк
прав и Борис прав и боксёр прав но если
вы будете всех слушать по чуть-чуть то
вы окажетесь
нигде вы не окажетесь специалистом ни в
чём включайте критическое мышление на
этапе выбора блогера или эксперта Но
после того как вы выбрали И посчитали
что он опытный человек а что он Практик
и что его знания наиболее близки к вам
то подписывайтесь на все его каналы И
слушайте всё о чём он говорит Не надо
метаться и слушать всех остальных это
второй лайфхак который я хотел бы вам
порекомендовать Вы знаете для для
саморазвития нужно не количество знаний
Вернее я так сказал бы для саморазвития
вам нужно не количество полученных
знаний вам нужно количество применённые
знаний А это совсем другое проблема
сегодняшнего мира ведь не в том что
знаний мало и проблема не в том что
экспертов мало а пробле проблема в том
что очень мало людей
которые что-то делают и применяют в
своей жизни приведу свой пример я
например могу смотреть какое-то
обучающее видео например оно может быть
двадцати тно видео но я смотрю 40 минут
час полтора часа Это не то что я смотрю
на замедленной скорости Нет я слушаю
видео как только появилась какая-то
стоящая мысль я останавливаю видео
открываю свою записную книжку и
записываю эту мысль и все свои мысли
которые ассоциируются с этой мыслью я
вспоминаю те случаи которые у меня в
жизни похожие случались и так далее
Кстати о чём я вас и прошу сразу же
Напишите в комментариях были ли у вас в
жизни такие случаи когда вы смотрели
видео вам встречалось очень много
полезных умных мыслей вы хотели записать
откладывали на потом а потом натыкались
на другое видео опять думали вот
классное видео надо записать не
записывали потом натыкались на третье
видео в результате вы не помните ни
одной нормальной мысли и всех
просмотренных видео поэтому друзья очень
важно важно не количество просмотренных
видео важно не количество полученных
знаний а важно количество применённые
знаний Если вы будете смотреть меньше
видео но применять больше из того что
услышали ваша жизнь кардинально
изменится ещё один момент который я
хотел бы упомянуть Дело в том что очень
много сейчас блогеров которые продвигают
наставничество своё обучения менторство
и так далее я не против этого среди них
наверное очень много достойных и но вы
просто должны в голове держать одну вещь
что пользу от любого наставничества
менторства сопровождения вы будете
получать только в том случае если будете
применять их знания и Если вы не будете
метаться ведь секрет ещё раз подчеркну
это не в знаниях которые вы получаете а
секрет в тех знаниях которые вы
применяете которые вы внедряет в свою
жизнь и вопрос даже не в блогере который
там обещает вам настав все знания
которые необходимы вам для изменения
вашей жизни Они уже существуют и вы
должны соответственно чётко понимать что
этот блогер Вам даст он даст вам знания
или он даст вам контроль над вами
сопровождение или исправление ошибок или
что он даст подойдите осознанно к выбору
блогера или эксперта который предлагает
вам какие-либо свои продукты и чётко
сформируйте запрос что вы от него хотите
получить мне задают вопросы по по поводу
того Сколько стоит платить за какие-то
курсы или наставничество блогеров
экспертов и так далее ребята цена - Это
вопрос абсолютно индивидуальный и цена
напрямую зависит не от тех знаний
которые дают а от того сколько вы
сможете извлечь то есть Вопрос не в том
что сколько вам дают А вопрос в том
сколько вы сможете из этого извлечь
пользы для себя поэтому А чем больше вы
платите это абсолютно не значит что вы
больше получите или больше извлек то что
дают вам а это зависит от блогера а то
что вы извлек это зависит от вас же
поэтому я ещё раз говорю если вы сможете
осознанно извлекать пользу из знаний не
гоняясь за большим количеством а гоняясь
больше за тем чтобы внедрять это в свою
жизнь то вам вполне достаточно того
бесплатного контента который сегодня
есть на просторах социальных сетей